these are extraordinary times and we  face an extraordinary challenge the  dramatic achievements in space which  occurred in recent weeks should have  made play to us all the impact of this  adventure on the minds of men everywhere  now it is time to take longer strides  time for a great new American Enterprise  time for this nation to take a clearly  leading role in space achievement which  in many ways may hold the key to our  future on earth I believe that this  nation should commit itself to achieving  the goal of landing a man on the moon  and returning him safely to the earth  [Music]  we set sail on this gem sea because  there is new knowledge to be gained  and we help decide whether this new  ocean will be a sea of peace or a new  terrifying theater of war  but why some say the moon  why climb the highest mountain  we choose to go to the moon in this  the other things not because they are  easy but because they are hard  [Music]  you